[Applause]
[Music]
joining us now with more insight on
where investors should put their money
we've got o'leary ventures chairman mr
wonderful himself kevin o'leary kevin
always a pleasure to get some of your
time and thanks for taking it here with
us this morning first and foremost as
you think about and kind of encapsulate
the month that july has been within the
broader backdrop of the declines that
we've seen in the equity markets over
the course of this year where do you
look for opportunities to still put your
money to work
well what's changed in the narrative of
the market in july specifically was the
idea that we actually could have an
engineered soft landing as opposed to a
hardcore recession and that while that
was a 10 probability just 90 days ago
it's a 50 50 bet right now and so as a
result um investors are starting to
place bets in places that they have
historically known come back quickly
after a recession so tech for example
got absolutely slaughtered and yet very
large names are selling at a discount to
where they traditionally were just three
months ago and so they're picking up a
bid now you're starting to see that and
then the results coming in like the
amazon results even microsoft sold off
still had strong outcomes so the
market's kind of debating
where to go
in a soft landing and there are some
sectors that will do better than others
and on top of all that you've got to
change the political environment the
buildback better bill
is probably going to arrive under a
trillion dollars while it's very
inflationary it's it's a big peel back
from the 3 trillion proposed originally
if it passes at all i mean it's still a
debate as we get to the midterms i like
the market right here i like buying
things at a discount um and july taught
every investor that you know age old
adage you can't time the market if you
were not in the market in july you might
have missed 50 of this year's returns
and so at this point in time we know
part of the inflationary environment it
certainly does hinge not just on what
the fed is going to do to combat
inflation but as well from the consumer
perspective
how quickly some of the supply chain
concerns are eased and where much of
their dollars are going right now on
fuel and energy prices too when that
starts to come back down and so with all
of that in mind if we see a resolve in
the supply chain issues and if you're
seeing any of that please do let us know
you know will that start to cool some of
the consumer concerns that they've seen
thus far
i'm not as optimistic on supply chain i
live with it every day across 50
different private companies we're
investors in we monitor this on a weekly
basis it's still very broken it's really
hard to get product out of the ports
very very difficult sometimes you're
when you're manufacturing something and
you're missing primary parts it slows
the entire process down and that's
exactly the situation we're in also for
every job we have
open we're having a really hard time
filling it so the we're in a really
strange situation now
there are you know two jobs for every
available employee in america and so
this is unusual that we'd be in
technically what should be a slowdown
according to you know many market
pundits and yet we're at full employment
under four percent unemployment right
now so
it's challenging i i think the way to
think about it is there's not going to
be a lot of relief on inflation because
if we pump another
600 billion dollars free cash which is
basically what this build back better is
into the market after putting six
trillion of free money in
there's a reason we have inflation we
just print too much money and so you
know you can be pro or con the bill but
the fact is it's free money and that's
that's going to be difficult next year
as inflation will continue i think to be
around six seven eight percent
while meanwhile it's very hard to get
that kind of return on any kind of fixed
income vehicle so i i would think
investors will still favor equities but
we'll have a lot more volatility in the
market over the next 12 months kevin
just given your access to all the
companies that you work with and all the
leaders do you think we're in our
pre-recession right now
every recession has its own personality
uh this one is
different there's no question about it
it's self-imposed
there's there's two major sources that
consumers feel in in
inflationary times that re usually
trigger a recession one is energy prices
and food prices and we have inflation in
both of those
but they're all in some ways
self-inflicted energy is just bad policy
shutting down pipelines removing the
leases from the gulf of mexico and
alaska
all of that was a mistake can't have an
economy without hydrocarbons and now
we've figured that out we're trying to
change it in this bill a little bit so
hopefully that can be fixed but it'll
it'll take a long time and here's the
primary reason that nobody really talks
about
we haven't built a refinery in this
country since the 70s we are down we
need three more refineries and the
administration recently cancelled one
that was about to come online so we
can't actually make any more gasoline
than we're making right now and
hopefully we don't have a catastrophe in
one of the existing refinements like a
flood or a storm or whatever that takes
more capacity offline so that's very
very broken even the visit that biden
made to saudi arabia asking for more
crude they said to what's the point of a
shipping or crew to you can't refine it
it's a good point but i think it's
another mistaken policy food price
inflation has a lot to do with supply
chain breakdown um there are parts of
the country that are not served protein
because they can't get the truckers or
they can't get the logistics worked out
hopefully that gets fixed but but this
this recession or this slowdown
doesn't look like it's going to be a
hard one it's going to be an economic
slowdown
but probably not as harsh as as historic
recessions that usually last for 18
months and i think the primary reason is
free money from helicopters never stops
we're printing more and more and more
money than ever before in any economy
ever and if this bill goes through it's
even more money and the only negative to
that is perpetual inflation
that's what the outcome is kevin you
don't sound like you have a lot of
confidence in the federal reserve
getting things right here
i i'm giving them more credit than i
would have 90 days ago because this last
rate hike of 75 basis points with more
dovish
uh
you know
verbiage if you want to call it that the
idea that they could pause as they see
what the outcomes are going to be the
market took that 75 basis point uh rate
hike and actually celebrated it that it
wasn't 100 basis points and that powell
was talking about maybe
you know being stop and see what the
results are of these moves in assessment
if the data changes but i would say
there's probably another 75 basis points
of rate hikes before he stops but even
that leaves us at historically low
interest rates so it's not as impactful
as history in other times the 70s for
example when we had interest rates as
high as 17 18 19
we're not in that place right now
because this economy is far more
productive
kevin just want to come back to
something you were mentioning a moment
ago with regard to energy prices
specifically right now and there is this
whole other headwind that over the
course of the year we've had to navigate
through on oil and that is the war in
ukraine and so the acknowledgment of
that
in combination with even prior to that
the printing of money that had to take
place from the fed to really counter the
effects the economic detriment that we
were assuming would be incurred as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic
what could we have done differently i
mean 2020 is is hindsight but at this
point in time it seems like we're just
trying to course correct the ship here
i'm not sure um
that's 100 percent
accurate and i'll tell you why
when you have a strong economy and the
metric you look at is employment
it's not really necessary to keep
printing money i mean we have an
extraordinary situation here with the
back end of the pandemic the last 12
months we kept printing money and
incentivized people not to go to work
which is if you look at how broken
transportation is right now we can't get
people to come and work at the airlines
we can't get people to work in security
we we
we've canceled 20 of all the flights in
america ask anybody that's taken a trip
lately to any major airport it's a
disaster part of that is a result of
just giving free money to everybody all
of the time and saying look stay at home
stay on your sofa we've had a whole
bunch of people just go out of the
economy because their bank accounts are
fat uh they've got lots of free
incentives now many of these programs
have stopped but it was a lot of money
and it may take a year or two before
people say well you know there's no
there's no more free cash i got to get
back to work but that's part of the
problem and and the other area that is
is concerning is when you have a digital
economy which is what emerged out of the
pandemic where everything is done online
and people don't have to go into the
office anymore and by the millions
they're not you have a new economy you
have a you have something that never
existed before you've got to understand
what that economy is before you start
stimulating it with even more free money
even tax policy the idea of a 15
minimum corporate tax rate
that's not a good move because you want
to keep our economy competitive and the
whole idea is when you look at a bill
like the buildback better bill does that
make america more competitive or less
competitive and i'd argue less if you
like that video wait did you see my next
one don't forget to click right over
here and subscribe